it is a living breathing artistic
project where the canvas is the body the
paint Inked onto the skin each person
with a different story to tell
with the goal to bring people from all
over the world together who've made a
permanent tribute to the 1948 Universal
Declaration of Human Rights on
themselves I've never had a tattoo
before and I never thought I'd get one
but when I read about this project I
just thought it was so powerful and
important and the fact that it connects
so many of us around the world I was
just like that's the one reason why I'd
get one this project is inspired by the
Declaration itself all
6773 letters that all human beings are
born free and equal in dignity and
rights but it's not just about the
letters it's about the people themselves
their stories and their lives
yeah it's just it's a scratch yeah for
Ali it is about her commitment to
helping young people and empowering them
to know about their human rights working
for and with young people is kind of a
specific passion of mine and
they're the future and we need to
support them so the idea that I'm kind
of imprinting that message on myself
feels really like important and helpful
it is the biggest art project of its
kind for the past 11 years artist and
founder sandov and bustle has toured 77
countries to raise awareness of the
Declaration and to meaningfully connect
those taking part
it is partially self-funded sometimes
grants or donations by a pay as much as
you want system go back to the project
so it can take place in venues that
can't cover the cost
it's also a reminder of the message at
the heart of the document we are
carrying this declaration together and
making it come alive as an artwork it's
not signed by me it's signed by all
those thousands of people so that in
that way it's Community artwork rather
than my artwork so I'm merely
the architect of the concept
from Mexico to Nepal and Zimbabwe one by
one letter by letter
a testament to the document that
enshrines our human rights is being
etched out
connecting
reminding and uniting Sony Gallego Al
Jazeera Manchester
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera